family and friends are remembering the
man who died after what police are
calling a road rage incident 73-year-old
marlon smith died yesterday after being
run over by a vehicle on boulder highway
and desert inn
smith's best friend spoke to victoria
saha reflecting on a man lost too soon
to a senseless tragedy
i hope they live in the shame of this
the rest of their lives
harsh words from marlin smith's best
friend larry gandy to the person who ran
smith over on tuesday
stay in jail police say the driver of a
suburban was said to have cut smith off
smith honked a passenger in the suburban
through a beer can at smith's jeep
smith then got out of his car to
confront the occupants
and was run over gandhi says smith's
wife
saw the whole thing it's just
disheartening there's
there's no punishment grave enough for
these guys gandy describes smith who
also went by the name
fuzzy by his motorcycle group as a
kind-hearted person
just a sweet guy one time my motorcycle
broke down
he came over here at night and we worked
for three hours we went and bought
parts we went all over the place just he
just didn't want to leave me stranded
gandy saw smith about two weeks ago
and now all he has left are memories of
their motorcycle rides
a sadness that i can't explain to you
you know when you lose a brother
who survived vietnam and
all the hell you went through and then
to
be run over by two guys in the street
and left in the hot pavement to die
you know in front of his poor little
wife
the man smith used to ride motorcycles
with will be hosting a ride
this saturday in honor of him reporting
from boulder highway and desert inn
victoria saha
8 news now the family has set up a
gofundme to pay for funeral expenses you
can find that if you'd like to help out
over on our website